so now let me explain why
donald trump is panicking why he has
replaced his campaign manager
with only three and a half months to go
before the election
five new election polls were released
yesterday
and joe biden is ahead by as little as
three points
in the right-leaning rasmussen poll and
by as much as
15 points nationally in the latest
quinnipiac university poll
in that same quinnipiac poll donald
trump's approval
has collapsed to 36
no president has had a 36 approval
this close to their re-election
uh election day potential re-election
election day
for a very very long time i i think this
is actually worse than george h.w bush
in 92 but i'd have to go back and look
so let's look at the new polling we got
yesterday just a ton of new polls
five general election polls nbc news
wall street journal says biden is up by
11.
cnbc says biden is up 10. rasmussen as i
mentioned
that's the right wing pollster the best
one for trump has biden up only
three quinnipiac is the most insane one
which says biden is winning by 15.
and then the economist yougov poll
released yesterday says biden is up by
nine
you also have some interesting state
polls one from this morning in arizona
says biden is up five in arizona a north
carolina
poll from yesterday says biden is up one
florida poll says biden up seven which
if biden wins florida by seven you're
looking at a historic defeat for donald
trump
big if big big big if uh in pennsylvania
biden is up eight
and in michigan wisconsin and a
different arizona poll
joe biden is up by six and then if you
look at texas we we saw one poll earlier
this week that had biden up five in
texas
the latest poll out of texas has trump
up two but understand that
i don't really think texas is a place
biden's going to win
but trump won texas by nine in 2016.
if trump only wins texas by two that is
a major signal about
trouble for donald trump nationally so
let's pick one of these and look a
little more closely at it the quinnipiac
poll
not only does it have joe biden up 15.
it has trump approval at 36
with 60 percent disapproving and the
internals on specific issues are
important to look at so
let's put up on the screen and i'll tell
you what we're looking at here
this is the quinnipiac poll key issues
trump versus biden on handling a crisis
biden leads 5738 by 19 points
on handling health care biden leads 58
to 35 that's 23 points
on coronavirus response biden leads 59
to 35
on addressing racial inequality just
brutal biden ahead by
32 points and this is maybe the most
interesting one to me
on handling the economy biden is now
ahead of trump 50 to 45.
that's the most important factor to me
because we often have this situation
where republicans are just more trusted
on the economy
i discussed with you last week how it's
not really borne out by the facts
stock market does better under
democratic presidents
unemployment is lower under democratic
presidents on average
recessions are more likely under
republican presidents
inflation is lower under democratic
presidents etc etc
but the stereotype is that republicans
are good for the economy and for
business even though it's actually not
true
the fact that joe biden now leads trump
by five
on the economy is massive because that
was essentially trump's last stand
so now what we've got it right we can
all just kind of hang for the next four
months
no no no no everyone must vote
do not become complacent even for
a second we don't have it trump knows
he's up against the wall
trump knows that it takes eight to ten
weeks to flatten the curve
and that that's getting us dangerously
close to election day and that the cases
are still going up not down
so he knows he needs dirty tricks okay
he knows he needs
deceptive online campaigns voter
suppression
trying to hide coronavirus data or data
or both really
uh so do not become complacent even for
a moment and we'll have more coverage of
this
and this latest polling on the david
pakman show instagram page
that's davidpakmanshow on instagram
follow us there
and we will have much more for you right
after this short break
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs with the
same level of quality and comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get twenty percent off
your entire order when you get there by
going to
all form dot com slash pacman i've also
put the link right underneath this video